with cells that leave little room for
social distancing and a lifestyle
particularly prone to the spreading of
infectious disease advocates for the
nation's more than 2 million inmates are
sounding the alarm about the corona
virus in jails and prisons people live
in very close quarters sleep in very
close quarters eat in very close
quarters are constantly with engaging
with each other in ways that that it's
impossible to stem additionally you have
staff coming in from the outside
corrections officers health care workers
who are bringing the virus with them
bringing the virus out and that's why
many officials have called jails and
prisons petri dishes federal prisons are
keeping inmates locked in their cells
while most state facilities have
eliminated visits here in New York more
than 200 inmates and corrections staff
have tested positive for the corona
virus and it's spreading in jails and
prisons elsewhere around the country as
well in order to contain it officials
have authorized the release of thousands
of inmates considered high risk for the
disease California has authorized the
early release of 3,500 inmates while
other state and local facilities
consider similar measures but critics
say many are being released without
proper testing or support New York
City's top prosecutors accuse the
Commissioner of Corrections of
authorizing sex offenders and domestic
abusers for release in a quote seemingly
haphazard process which could compound
the possible health safety and other
risks both to the communities and to the
individuals at issue those who work with
inmates say the pandemic highlights
longstanding shortcomings with health
care and reintegration efforts for the
world's largest prison population Ghana
just released almost a thousand people
by way of presidential pardon Iran
released 84,000 we're seeing prison
riots all over the world in Colombia in
Brazil in Italy of course and so there
is a collective outcry here and also a
collective radical
test of the system
an already overtaxed system straining to
contain a new pandemic Kristin salumi al
Jazeera New York